what ideas do you believe might be true
that most or at least many people
disagree with you with
let's say in the space of machine
learning
well it depends who you talk about but
um i think
so certainly there is uh
a bunch of people who are nativists
right who think that a lot of the basic
things about the world are kind of
hardwired in our in our minds
um things like you know the world is
three-dimensional for example is that
hardwired
things like uh you know object
permanence is something that we learn uh
you know before the age of three months
or so or are we born with it and there
are you know very disa you know
white disagreement among the you know
cognitive scientists
for this i think those things are
actually very simple to learn
um
you know is it the case that the
oriented edge detectors in v1 are
learned or are they hardwired i think
they are learned they might be learned
before both because it's really easy to
generate signals from the retina that
actually will train edge detectors so
um and again those are
things that can be learned within
minutes of uh opening your eyes right i
mean
you know since the 1990s we have
algorithms that can learn oriented
detectors completely unsupervised with
the equivalent of a few minutes of
real-time so
so those things have to be learned
um and there's also those you know mit
experiments where you kind of
plug the optical nerve on the auditory
cortex of a baby ferret right and that
auditory cortex becomes a visual cortex
essentially
so you know clearly
this running taking place there
so you know i think a lot of what people
think are so basic that they need to be
hardwired
i think a lot of those things are
learned because they are easy to learn
jesus so you put a lot of
value in the power of learning what kind
of things do you suspect might not be
learned
is there something that could not be
learned
so your intrinsic drives are not learned
they they there are the things that you
know make humans uh
human or make you know
cats different from dogs right it's the
basic drives that are kind of hard-wired
in our bezel ganglia
i mean there are people who are working
on on this kind of stuff this is called
intrinsic motivation in the context of
reinforcement running so these are
objective functions where the reward
doesn't come from the external world
it's computed by your own brain your own
brain computes
whether you're happy or not right it
measures your degree of uh
comfort or in comfort
and
and because it's your brain computing
this presumably knows also how to
estimate gradients of this right so
so it's easier to to learn when your
objective is intrinsic
so that has to be hardwired
the critic that makes long-term
prediction of the outcome which is the
eventual
result of this that's learned
uh and perception is learned and your
model of the world is learned but let me
take take an example of you know why the
critic
i mean example of how the critic might
be learned right if i uh if i come to
you um
you know i reach across the table and i
pinch your arm right complete surprise
for you
you would not have expected this i was
expecting that the whole time but yes
right let's say for the sake of the
story yes
um okay your visual ganglia is going to
light up because it's going to hurt
right
and now your model of the world includes
the fact that i may pinch you if i
approach my uh
my uh don't trust humans right
my hand to your arm so if i try again
you're gonna recoil and that's your
critic
uh your predictive
you know your predictor of your uh
ultimate pin uh
system
that predicts that something bad is
going to happen and you recoil right to
avoid it so even that can be learned
that is drawing definitely this is what
allows you also to uh you know define
some goals right so
um the fact that you know you're a
school child you wake up in the morning
and you go to school and you know
it's not because you necessarily like
waking up early and going to school but
you know that there is a long-term
objective you're trying to optimize
you